hi i'm beau carnes with freecodecamp.org
i'm going to show you how to code a
discord bot with
javascript that runs completely in the
cloud
for free i already made a course about
coding a discord bot with python
and you can get the link to that up here
in the corner or down in the description
we're going to use a few different tools
including the discord api
a few javascript libraries and a cloud
computing platform
called replit you probably already know
what discord is
and what a discord bot is since you are
watching this tutorial
but just in case you don't let me give
you a brief overview
discord is an app used for real-time
text chat
discord servers are set up by people and
generally are focused on a certain
community
many groups and organizations have
discord servers for people to chat with
each other
a discord server often has many channels
which are different rooms you can chat
in
a discord bot is a user in your discord
server
that is controlled by a program instead
of a person
you can code a discord bot to make it do
whatever you want
there are many things discord bots are
often used for they can be used to chat
respond to messages manage servers play
music
and more you can also use webhooks with
a discord bot
to do things like give real-time updates
on a github repository
the bot we will create in this course is
called encouragebot
it can tell people inspirational quotes
that it gets from an api also when user
says a sad word
the bot will respond with an encouraging
phrase
users can also add or remove encouraging
phrases that the bot uses
directly from discord the first step for
creating a discord bot
is to make sure you have a discord
server to add the bot to
you may already have one but let me just
show you how to set one up really quick
in case you don't already have one
so you're gonna have to go to
discord.com and log into discord
and then you just click the plus button
here to add a server
and i'll say for me and my friends and
i'll just call it
robot family server
okay let's create that and now
we have our server okay so before we can
code our bot using python and using the
discord api
we must first create a discord bot
account
right within discord so you're going to
have to go to the discord
developer portal i'll put the link in
the description
but it's just discord dot com slash
developers
slash applications so once you're on the
applications page
you're going to click this new
applications button
and then we're going to create a name
for it this spot
is going to send friendly encouragements
to people
from in discord so i'm going to call it
encourage
bot okay
i'll create that okay now i'm going to
go to the bot tab here
and then i am going to click add
bot and say yes
do it okay we'll keep the dis
the default settings as a public bot
and then we won't require the oauth to
grant the code grant
so now the the bot has been created
the next step is to copy the bot token
okay so i'll just click copy to copy the
token
we're going to need that later now this
token is your bot's password
so make sure not to share with anybody
it could allow someone to log into your
bot and do
all sorts of bad things and it could
even allow someone to
mess with your server and also you can
obviously regenerate the token if it
accidentally gets shared
so now we have to invite the bot to our
server we have the bot user and we have
to get it into our server
to do that we're going to have to create
an invite url
for it so let's go to the oauth 2
tab here and now we're just going to go
to the scope section
since this is a bot we'll just click bot
here
now we have to scroll down a little bit
more and go to the bot
permissions section so we'll choose the
the permissions uh we want for the bot
our bot is going to be you mainly used
for text messages
so we don't need a lot of permissions so
your bot may do different things but
let's just
choose some of these here actually we'll
do all of them on this line
except send tts messages now you do need
to be
careful with this administrator
permissions
if you give your bot administrator
permissions it has a it will
be able to control your server in ways
that you may not actually want
and then i guess the last one we need to
add is the view channels our bots going
to have to view the channels
so after selecting the appropriate
permissions
we'll click the copy button right here
and this will copy a
url that can be used to add the bot to a
server
and i guess we'll also have to recopy
the bot key we copied the bot key
earlier but now it's been recopied with
this url so we'll have to come back
later to get the bot key
but now let's just open up a new tab and
i'm going to go to this url
okay so now we have to choose the server
we want to add the bot to i'll
choose robot family server the only
option
but you will probably have more than
more options so we'll click continue
and we want to approve that we want to
do all these things we want to authorize
the bot
for all these things
and i'm not a robot and the bot is
authorized
that means the bot has joined the server
so if we actually go
over into our server we can see
encouragement just slid
into the server but also you see over
here that the bot
is offline it's not going to be online
till we write our code that creates the
bot and run the code
and speaking of code it's time to start
that
now i said earlier that you don't have
to install anything you don't have to
use any
software except your web browser we are
going to be creating
the entire discord bot right in the
cloud
on replit the website for replit
is repl.it and
replit is an online ide that you can
just use in your web browser
so it makes it a lot easier to code
things if you don't have to install any
special software on your computer
and then you can log into it from
multiple browsers multiple computers and
then you can
easily access your code in your programs
no matter what computer you're using
so we're going to make our on this and
then it'll also be completely hosted in
the cloud
we can even run the bot on this website
so we don't have to run it on our local
computer and that will make it so we can
keep the bot running
even if our computer shuts down or what
we're gonna where we close the browser
tab or anything like that
i'll show you how to make the bot so
it'll keep running in the background
continuously and then you don't have to
worry about it
if you don't already have account you're
going to sign up but i'm going to log in
here
i'm going to show you how to use replit
to create the bot from scratch
but just in case you click the link in
the description to the completed
bot you're going to want to click fork
here
and you don't really want to start
editing you probably want to fork it and
then create your own copy
and then start editing instead of trying
to request
edit my copy okay this is replit
so let me show you how to start a new
project
we're just going to click on new new
reple here
and then i'm we're going to be using
node.js so i'll click on node.js
and then if we want we can name it or
you can use the default name
i'm going to call it encourage bot
js and then create reple
we're going to be using the discord.js
node library to write the code for the
bot discord.js
is an api wrapper for discord that makes
it easier to create a discord bot
in node.js or javascript okay we're in
our project
you can see that we have our files here
we have our code that we're going to
write here
and then we have a console over on the
side and then there's some different
tabs
we are only going to be mainly using the
files tab here but
we'll also be using the database tab
later
but for now let's get started so
first we're going to add the discord.js
library
so i'll add const discord
equals require
discord dot js
now replit will automatically install
this dependency
when you press the but the the run
button so that's one cool thing about
repli is that the
dependencies are installed automatically
and if you ever have a problem you can
always go into the shell
and you can install anything manually in
the shell
but let's go back over to the console
discord.js
revolves around the concept of events an
event is something you listen to
and then respond to for example when a
message happened
you will receive an event about it that
you can respond to
we're going to start by making a very
simple bot
this is a bot that's going to respond to
messages
this is taken directly from the
discord.js
documentation so we'll start by making a
very simple one
and then we'll continue to add to and
make it more complex
and make it work for our purposes so
after this first line we need to get a
client
const client equals
new discord dot
client
so this is our discord client that we'll
be working with
to connect to our discord server this is
the client for the discord.js library
okay i talked about
different events so our client is going
to
respond to it different types of events
one event is the ready event
a ready event means that the bot has
successfully connected to our discord
server
and is ready to do more things so let's
add
code now to respond to the ready event
so
you start with client
dot on so on what on what event well the
event is going to be ready
so on the ready event once it's ready
to start working once it's connected to
our server it's going to
call this callback function so let's
make this callback function here
and we're just going to console.log
something
console.log
logged in as
and then we're going to get the client
name or the username
the name of the bot client.user.tag
okay now we're going to respond to a
different event the event is a message
so whenever the bot sees a message in
the discord server
it will get the message event and it
will do something whenever there's a
message
so client dot on
message and then it will call this
callback function
we'll get access to the message through
this
parameter here
[Music]
and we're going to check to see what the
message actually is
message.content
is the text of the message so we're
going to check for this example
if the message is the word ping
and if so then we'll do something
so we're going to reply message.reply
pong so it will the our bot will
actually reply with another message
in the chat and the message will be pong
okay now that we have our our event set
up the ready event and the message
event we need to have our client
log in to the server so to log into the
server
we'll do client dot login
now here we need to put our token
but we're not going to actually you
could put your token as a string here
remember the token is the thing when we
create the bot on the developer page
we copied the token and if if you
don't have that anymore you can go back
to the developer page and copy the token
again
you could put the token as a string
right here but we're not going to do
that
and the reason is because anything on
replit
can be accessed by anyone on the
internet
so we don't want anybody to be able to
have access to our
token that's like a password for our bot
and then anybody could actually
use our bot to do anything that they
wanted we don't want that so we need to
have a figure out we need a way to
keep our token a secret and the way
we're going to do that is when it within
an
environment variable replica has a
special way of doing that
we are going to create our environment
variable in just a second
let's access it right now and then we'll
create it so to access a
environment variable we do process
dot env dot and then the name of the
environment variable
which in this case is going to be token
so
now we have to find a place to put this
so
this is how it works in replin we're
going to create a new file
and i'm going to call it dot env
anything
in a dot env file is hidden from the
rest of the world
and you can see we already have it here
so we have
the the word token you're gonna have to
put the word token and then an equal
sign
and then you paste in your token
that you got for your bot
so in this case this is my token and now
that we have our token stored in our
environmental variable
it can get the token and the emv file
like i said it cannot be accessed by
nobody can see except you
any other file everyone can see but the
emv only you can see it
and that's how we can get that token
that nobody else can see
i guess all of you just saw because i
just saw it on my screen but
more usually you're not gonna be making
a video so nobody will actually see the
actual environment variable
so it's time i'm going to run this
program
okay it says we're logged in so that
worked
maybe you may have had a problem if
somehow it didn't automatically install
discord.js
in that case like i said you can install
in the shell but
everything worked for me so i and i am
going to go over to my discord server
right now
and see what it looks like okay it shows
that encouraged bot
is logged in so i'm going to do a chat
i'm going to type in
ping pong and see since it's a reply
it says my name because encouragement is
replying to me
and saying pong so it worked we have a
bot
and it works now that we have a basic
bot working
we'll improve it it's called encourage
bot for a reason
the bot will respond with a message of
encouragement whenever
someone sends a message containing a sad
or depressing
word anyone will be able to add
encouraging messages for the bot to use
and the user submitted messages will be
stored in the replica database
the bot will also return a random
inspirational quote from an api
when someone types the message inspire
into the chat
we'll start with adding the inspire
feature we're going to get
inspirational quotes from an api called
zenquotes.io
now this it could actually work with any
api
you can use any api in just any api
that's going to return
json or any sort of string you can use
and then you can get that information
and then you can actually return the
string
as a message with your bot but i just
found this zing quotes
io as a easy way to get a
quote an encouraging or motivating quote
that we can
return with our bot so since we are
going to be
calling this api we're going to need to
import the node fetch
module so up here i am going to
do const
fetch equals require
[Music]
node fetch so we will be able to use
that to
call that api and now
let's make a function called get quote
that will be able to be called to get a
quote from the api
so function get quote
[Music]
inside this function we are going to
return
the quote and inside this function
we are going to fetch the quote and
actually we're going to return it so
return
and then i will do my fetch command
fetch
and then here is where we put the url
https
colon slash zen quotes
dot io slash api let's make more room
here so you can see everything that i'm
typing in
x and it's going to be slash random
okay after we fetch that information
do dot then this is an asynchronous call
so first it gets the information it may
not get it right away so but it's going
to
wait till it gets the information from
this url
then it's going to do something with
that data
so let's put the callback function
they'll call
that we'll call after gets that data
[Music]
we're going to return the result
but we're going to convert it to json
[Music]
and then we are going to do something
else with that data
that json that data that's returned
we're going to return we're going to
format it in the exact way we want to be
formatted
so we have the data and let me just type
in this
okay to figure out exactly what i want
to return here and how to format this
i had to use trial and error so
i got the information from this url
and i converted json and then i figured
out that the queue
is quote and the a is the author
so this is going to put the quote here
and then it's going to be
there's there'll be a dash and then
it'll be the author you'll see exactly
what it looks like when we test this out
but so this is going to it's going to
return a random inspirational quote
and to get the information into the
format i wanted it's going to look like
that
and so it's going to return the quote
when someone calls this function
so let's update our message event here
so it will return a quote at the right
time
we're going to add something where first
we're going to add a new thing
we're going to check to see if the
message is from the bot
if the bot ever says anything we don't
want the bot to
to respond to itself so if
message.author that means if the bot is
author of the message just return
so we're not going to do anything in
that case but if
message.content equals well it's not
going to be equal in
ping anymore we're looking for the word
inspire
so if it senses that there's a message
that's that's
inspire then we're gonna do the get
quote function
get quote dot
then so you see where we're
respond we're returning the resp the
what's the result of this fetch
and so this is also a promise
that we can then this is an async call
so
once we get the result then we're going
to do something
then we're going to take the quote
[Music]
and we'll do message dot channel
dot send so this is going to send a
message to the whole channel
and the message is going to be the quote
okay let's try this out first i'll stop
it because it was already running before
but we need to start it again for the
new code
then i'll wait till it shows it's logged
in here
oh see it's installing the node.fetch
module now
okay we're logged in okay now i will
type
dollar sign inspire
they say love is the best investment the
more you give the more you get in return
audrey hepburn wow i feel very inspired
now
and just so you know it doesn't respond
like that to anything
if i say hello
it doesn't have a response it only
responds if it sees dollar sign
inspire now we will implement the
feature where the bot responds with
encouraging messages
when a user posts a message with a sad
word
so first we need to create an array that
contains the sad words that the bot will
respond to
so i'm going to go up here and i'm going
to create
an array it's going to be called sad
words and then i'll just have a list of
sad words
now you can use any list you want and
any sad words
probably sad depressed
unhappy
[Music]
angry and we'll just do those but you
can add
more to this list if you want now we'll
add an array of encouraging messages
that the bot will respond with so
let's add another array called
encouragements
const encouragement
cheer up
hang in there
you are a great person
or bot
[Music]
and like before feel free to add any
phrases you want or just change them up
i'm just using these three items for now
because later we'll add the ability for
users to add more encouraging phrases
for the bots to for the bot to use so
now we need to update our bot to use the
two lists we created
so let's go down to the message function
we're going to add another section here
and we're going to add a section that's
going to
check to see if the message contains a
word from the sad words list
and then if a sad word is found the bot
will send a random message of
encouragement
so let's add that this time i just
pasted in some code and we're going to
go over it
so this is how we're going to check if
the message
contains a word in the sad words list
so we start with sad words dot sum this
is an array method let me show you what
it's going to do
we're going to go through each item in
the array or in this case a word
and then we're going to check if
message.content.includes
if the message includes the word
and we're going to do that for every
word in the list
and this sad words that sum is going to
return true
if one or more of these things are true
and so if at least one of those words
in the list is in
the message it's going to be true so
then it's going to run the code here
so first we're going to create get a
single encouragement
so the encouragements list we have the
encouragements list and then we want a
random element
so this is how we get a random element
math.floor
rounds down math.random times
encouragements.length so this is just a
way to get a random index number
for the encouragements array and then
we're going to
get that random encouragement and then
message.
reply encouragement so it's going to
return that encouragement
okay let's stop this and then we're
going to restart it
okay we can test it i am sad
it says beaucards hang in there
that's very encouraging thank you
encourage bot
i am happy now
[Music]
and it doesn't respond at all because
now that i'm happy it doesn't need to
respond
but now i'm feeling depe i am feeling
[Music]
depressed
cheer up oh that makes me feel a lot
better
and you can see it's getting random
phrases hang in there
cheer up it includes my name here
because it's a reply
if we go back to our code you can see
that it's a message.reply
anytime it's a reply it's going to
include the name
the person who said the message and then
the new message which is the
encouragement
okay you basically know enough to make
your own bot
and you can go to the discord.js
documentation
to find out even more features you can
do with your discord bot
but now we're going to learn right now
how to implement more advanced features
with this bot
and store data using the replic database
so let's make it possible to update the
bot
right from discord a user should be able
to add more encouraging messages for the
bot to use
when it detects a sad word we're going
to be using
replete's built-in database to store
user-submitted messages
the database is a key value store that's
built into every replit
so if you click right here it says
database it's going to
show you all these database commands you
can use
so you're always you're going to have to
import the database at the top
you can create a new database we're
actually going to import some of these
commands right now so if we just go up
to the top here
and then right under my other require
i'm going to click insert here and it's
just going to put this code right in
here
const database equals require and then
it's going to get this database
library okay now we have to create a new
database
so we'll separate these require
statements from these other
new statements here so i'm going to
create a new
database
and when we run the code this will
automatically install
and if it doesn't or if you're doing it
on your local machine you can just go
over to the shell
and do npm install and then use this
for the name here so what we're going to
do down here
after the encouragements we're going to
initialize the database
with these three encouragements we're
going to just add those to the
to the database if they're not already
in the database
so this is how we're going to do that
db.get
encouragements so
we're going to get the encouragements
that are already in the database
well if this is the first time this
program runs there won't be any in there
but if the program has run previously
and it
are there's already encouragements in
the database then it'll get the list
of encouragements that are in the
database so this is the key
and where this key key value pairs so
this is the key
and then we're going to get the value
which to start off with would be null
but after we get the encouragements then
we're going to take those encouragements
[Music]
and then we're going to do this i'm
going to put this function here
if we're going to check if there are no
encouragements
if there are no encouragements
or
if the encouragements dot length
is less than one so if there's
zero encouragements then we're going to
add the encouragements
so there'll be always be at least
something to encourage people with
so and by the way the reason why we have
both of these
is because the first time this runs
encouragements will be
null but later incursions could be zero
so in either case
we want to do db.set
we're going to set the encouragements
key
going to set this to be the
encouragements well we want to set to be
these encouragements
but we're already using this variable
here and we're going to use
encouragements later so this is just
let's just change this to be called
starter encouragements so this is now
the starter encouragements and we're
going to set these encouragements to be
the starter encouragements
users will be able to add custom
encouraging messages for the bot to use
directly from the discord chat before we
add new commands for the bot
let's add two let's create two helper
functions that will add
custom messages to the database and
delete the messages
so right after this we're going to
create
a helper function function
[Music]
function update
encouragements
and it's going to take one argument an
encouraging message
[Music]
and so first we're going to get the list
of current encouraging messages
db.get
encouragements and then after we get
those encouragements
then we're going to take those
encouragements
and in this function we're going to do
something with them
so we're going to do encouragements
dot push we're going to push the new
message
onto this list onto this array
encouraging message
now we're going to do db.set we're going
to add this to the database
with the new then new encouraging
message on it so
encouragements that's the key and the
new value for that key
is going to be
encouragements okay now we have to make
another function
to delete the encouragements so function
[Music]
delete
[Music]
encouragement and this is going to take
an
index the index in the array
that needs to be deleted
[Music]
so first we're going to get it's
actually going to be
somewhat similar so i'm going to get
just copy this
then paste this in
but we are not going to be
pushing any new any new thing here so
what we're going to do instead
is if encouragement
dot length is
greater than the index we're only only
going to delete something
if the index is is actually an
appropriate
index so if the length is greater than
the index then it's part
then the index will actually apply to
this array
what we're going to do is
incur encouragements
dot splice this is how you remove an
item from
an array index 1.
so at the index we're going to remove
one item
and then we're going to just move this
up i'm going to cut this
[Music]
and put it here so now we're going to
set the encouragements again to be this
new encouragements
array that has the encouragements
removed that we want to remove
okay let's update this section now
so now we have to make sure that we are
using our list from the database
when we return a message when there's a
sad word
detected so let's add something here
we are going to have to get the the
messages from the database
so db.get
encouragements
dot then encouragement
and now all this code i'm just going to
cut that
and then put it in here
and this actually should be
encouragements
okay now let's make it so our bot will
respond to
two new commands so
if message dot content
dot starts starts
with so if the content
starts with dollar sign new
then we are going to do something
so first we have to figure out what the
new
the new message is so the person will be
typing
dollar sign new space and then they'll
put their new message
that should be should be added to the
list of encouragements
so the encouraging message is going to
equal
message dot content dot split
new
one so this is the message
and dot split is a javascript string
method and we're going to split
at this and make sure there's a space at
the end
because the person is going to type in
dollar sign new space
and then we want anything after that to
be the new message
so index 1 in the array because this is
going to create an array
and index one will be anything after
this so we'll get the
encouraging message and then
[Music]
update encouragements with the
encouraging message
and then after we do that we can send a
message to the whole channel
message.channel dot send
so our bot is about to send this message
new
encouraging
[Music]
there we go message added
oh when you see right here encouraging
there we go
new encouraging message added
okay now we have to do the same thing
with delete
so i'm just going to copy this whole
thing because it will be kind of similar
and then paste it here now we're looking
to see if the message the user types in
starts with d e
l for delete and we're splitting it at d
e l
and this is now going to be the index
the person is going to type in
dollar sign d e l space and they're
going to put
a number and the number is going to be
the index of the array that should be
deleted
since it's a number we should do parse
int to convert this to from a string to
an inch so
parse int and then i'm going to put this
in parentheses
so parseint and instead of update
encouragements we're going to be doing
delete encouragement and then i can put
the
index here and then message that channel
that send
new encouraging message deleted
okay we can test this out here
so i'll run the program
and we're logged in
i am sad hang in there
that's really encouraging well let's
become even more encouraging because i'm
going to add a new message
you are a great
person and also a great
singer hmm that would make me feel
encouraged
okay how about nice
avatar
[Music]
and how about
[Music]
that was a wonderful
message okay
now i'm going to see if it will use one
of those new
messages we added so i am sad
that was a wonderful message i am
depressed i guess that was a wonderful
message isn't that encouraging if i'm
saying that i'm sad but
you are a great person and also a great
singer now let's see if we can delete
one of these
so let's delete
i'll do del and i'll put index
zero and let me just delete a few of
them
now we should have deleted all three of
the initial messages
so if oops sad
let's see if we see any of the initial
messages
we're not seeing any we're only seeing
the new ones because all the initial
ones were deleted
okay now we're going to add the ability
to get a list of user submitted messages
right from discord and we'll we will add
the ability to turn
off and on whether the bot responds to
sad words
so to change whether it responds or not
we're going to add a new
variable or a new key value pair to the
database
so let me scroll up a little bit
and right before this where we
initialize the encouragements key value
pair
let's do the same thing with another one
db dot
[Music]
get responding
so this is a variable called responding
or the key value pair
so as we're trying to figure out if the
bot should be responding or not
then
[Music]
value will get whatever the initial
value is
[Music]
and let's check if it exists yet if if
value equals equals null
that means that this is the first time
the program has run so it's not in the
database yet
[Music]
then let's set it something set set it
to
[Music]
responding is going to equal
or be set to true
[Music]
now this will only happen if the value
equals null
so if you've run the program and you've
set this to false
the next time the program runs it won't
then be set to true it will still be
saved in the database
even if you stop and restart the program
okay so the whole point of that was to
change whether it responds to the sad
words or not
so let's add something else here
db.get responding
and we're trying to see if the if the
bots be responding or not
then responding
[Music]
now we're going to take this whole thing
here
and it's going to be inside
this other section
and let me indent this
so now we're going to check if
responding
is true and
this is true or it should be responding
there we go so now we're checking with
for two things to be true
before it sends the encouraging message
okay let's go down and we're gonna add
two commands two more commands
one of them will be to list all the
encouraging messages
and the other command will be to change
the responding
status to either true or false on or off
so if message.content
dot starts with
if it starts with list
then we're going to list all the
messages
so first we have to get the messages
db.get
encouragements
dot then encouragement
[Music]
and then actually this will be called
encouragements
[Music]
message.channel dot send
encouragements we'll send all the
encouragements to the channel as a
message
okay so for the next one let's just
copy this first line here
if dot starts with and this time it's
going to be
responding
[Music]
so that means we're changing the the
command is to
change whether the bot is going to
respond or not so let's get the value
first
value equals message dot
content dot split
responding with the space at the end
one this is just like before
and the value is either going to be
true or false so
if value dot
to lower case
[Music]
equals equals equals
true
then db dot set
responding
to true also message dot
channel dot send
[Music]
respond race
oh wait a second responding
is on
else so if it's anything
but true we'll assume it's false
so let me just copy this here
else set responding to false and
the message will be responding is off
the code for the bot is complete
we're going to test it out one more time
and then
i will show you how to make the bot
how to set up the bot to run
continuously
we'll run the program and it's logged in
okay let's just try to do a list
and let's see if i can add something to
the list
[Music]
and i'll do the list again
[Music]
and it adds the item i added the item
yes and now it's
on the list now it's even easier to
delete things so i'm going to delete
that was a wonderful message because we
don't want to respond with that if
someone says a sad message
so i will do dell that's
the index 2
and then i will do list
and oh you know this is wrong new
encouraging message deleted that doesn't
even make sense
this should just be encouraging message
deleted i don't know why i didn't notice
that before
so let's update that to
encouraging that's going to be new there
we go
looks like i have a few spelling errors
here okay responding
and then down here we have
responding i don't know why i can't
spell this
okay let's play that again hopefully we
don't have any errors
or run that again i keep saying play
because it looks like a play button
[Music]
and now i will list
and it's gone it doesn't say that was a
wonderful message anymore
sad oh i didn't mean
i shouldn't put the dollar sign but it
should still respond because it has the
word sad
[Music]
oh but it's not there's no space before
it so let's just
oh it is responding nice avatar said
you're a great person and
also a great singer now let's see if we
can turn it off and
on so responding
false or yeah false
responding is off so if i type in sad
it doesn't respond now i can turn it
back on responding
[Music]
respond thing true
responding is on so if i type in
depressed
you are a great person and also a great
singer
it works we've created the bot we've
tested it
everything works okay so our bot is done
but there's one more thing i want to
show you
which is how to make the bot run
continuously
as it is if you ever close your so if
you run the spot right now if i run this
bot and i ever close my tab or close my
browser
it will stop running but we want to make
it so it will just run in the background
so you don't even have to have your
computer on
for the discord bot to be running so
there's two ways to do it
one way is just to click right up here
and you can see it says this rebel can
be kept
always on and there normally would be
just
a an on button here to keep it on so
just keep running in the background even
if you close things
however you do have to upgrade so you do
have to upgrade to the
paid plan to have this built-in way to
keep the replica always on
so here's the pricing for the hacker
plan that repple offers
you get five rebels that are always on
if you if you get it and you also get a
bunch of storage
extra memory more speed and soon you'll
even get offline rebels
and seven dollars a month is pretty
reasonable it's just like you would pay
for any hosting
replied made this course possible
through a grant and they're
also offering three months free of this
hacker plan
to the first 1000 people that clink that
click the link in the description
with the coupon code but like i said
there's also a way to get your replit to
be always on for free without even
signing up for this
and i'm going to show you that right now
if you run your bot
in replit and then close the tab it's
running in your bot will just stop
running
however there is a workaround so the
work around without having to pay
anything
is that replica will continue running a
web server
even after the tab is closed but even
a web server will only run for up to an
hour without any use
so to keep the bot running continuously
we'll use another free service called
uptime robot that's at uptimerobot.com
it can be set up to ping the bot's web
server on replica every five minutes
and then with constant pings the bot
will never enter the sleeping stage
and will just keep running so we have to
do two things
we have to create the web server and
replit and
set up uptime robot to continually ping
the web server
so let me show you how we're going to
create the web server
first of all i'm going to create a new
file and just click add file and this is
going to be called server.js
okay and now we're going to be using
express to create the web server
okay so we'll do const express
equals require
express
and then wait to create the server so
const server
equals express
now that we have the server we need to
create a route
and the route is the thing that that's
going to be pinged
from uptime robot so here we go
server dot all
so this creates a new route at just
slash like
just at your root domain and it's going
to respond to all http requests that's
what this all is so like get
put post and it's just going to say
it's going to send back bot is running
so now that we have the server ready we
have to create a function that starts
the server
so function
and we're just going to be calling it
keep alive because it's going to keep
alive
our repli instance
server dot listen
we're gonna listen at port 3000
and then we're just going to log
something
whoops this should be equal sign
console.log
server is ready
so when this keep alive function is run
it's going to the server's gonna start
listening at port 300
3000 and it's going to log servers ready
and now we just have to export this so
we can import it and run it from our bot
file so module dot exports
equals keep alive
okay now let's make sure that when our
bot runs it automatically runs this
server
so let me go into our index.js
and then at the very top here
const keep alive
and require and then we're just going to
require the server that we just created
server then down here right before
our client logs in
keep alive so we'll start our server
we'll start that server function
okay now let's run this and see if the
server starts
oh uh actually we need to make keep a
lie not keep
live er so let's try that again
and we can tell that the server started
because it opened up a new window here
and it says
bot is running
so i'm going to copy there's a link
right here which i'm going to
select and copy this is our server link
that we're going to have to put into
uptime robot
so let's go set this up on uptime robot
to ping our server
every five minutes okay
uptime robot.com and you're either gonna
have to register or
log in then once you get logged in
you'll see this dashboard and there's
this add new monitor here so i'm gonna
click that
and monitor type this is going to be an
https monitor
and i can just call this encourage bot
and then i'll just paste in the url that
i copied from our replit
and then it's on every five minutes
and then if i want i can select myself
to notify if you want to be notified
when
something goes wrong but you know i'm
not going to notify myself
so i'm just going to do create monitor
and it's created
now our bot will continue running after
i close the tab or close the window
even if my computer is turned off the
discord bot will still just keep running
we're done we learned how to create a
discord bot we learned how to
make it continually run and now you know
enough
to start customizing this and creating
your own bot
i would recommend checking out the
discord.js
documentation to learn even more
commands you can add
okay you've reached the end go and
create your own bots
but remember use your code for good